Oh
okay
I should be live it's been a while since
I streamed
maybe a week for like five days or
something um but I see I'm live playing
chess for zero viewers okay um I'm gonna
play let me meet this first
I'm gonna play someone in the lobby the
stream is titled challenge me
oh wait a minute I have to say challenge
me on me chess org uh how do I change
this
hey Braden how's it going and I took 5
mins on my name thanks for hosting me
challenge me on reach estaat org updates
her occurred once
okay I'm not wait Braden is now hosting
me with 22 viewers Thank You Bradon
it keeps saying an error occurred I have
no idea why I refresh
i refresh everything I'm just trying to
change the stream title
um refresh
now it's showing I'm streaming on HS
that's a good sign
um I don't know if my internet slow or
if there's just lag with twitch
feel like there might just be lag with
twitch it's my ping-ping-ping okay pings
not too bad okay well thanks guys for
watching let me open up the chat again
what do you want the title I think the
title is now changed the title supposed
to be challenging me on me chess org
okay now it's updated great
yeah so um so send me a challenge if
anyone wants to play me I was gonna just
start a game with some random person
here let's play the twelve ninety sure
he's not seeing this coming I just want
to get a quick game and um hopefully
demonstrate how to beat a lower rated
player
use my English you've been awake for
thirty hours
so thirty hours ago
thirty hours ago it was like
12:00 p.m. yesterday
I'll be Central Time okay we're gonna
have a four nights typical opening among
low rated players and he plays a three
I've actually played this as white this
is a very tricky line so I play Bishop
c5 he can take on e5 the best move here
is d5 for black
hello to Riemann hypothesis thanks for
the comments good to see watching stream
and hello I didn't ship monk there Ida
nut chipmunk or is it a thin the
chipmunk
another new name uh hello to Nathan
Oh Nathan your playing Chicago opened I
was gonna stop by today but then a
tragedy struck I forgot my laptop
charger
I don't live like that close 9th floor
looks enticing
ina for thanks for the follow Aiden
um Queenie - such a weird move
so neither for Queenie for Zef cats
thanks for following deaf cat sounds
really familiar actually I think that's
another streamer if I'm not mistaken
feel free to say hi and the chats Zef
cats
still debating nine afore I guess
metaphor and then like Bishop d6 and
then castle I'll be happy
um yeah if you want to play me you can
challenge me on me chess if you don't
know how to challenge me on me chess you
can type in the Li chest command and
move on should be helpful of some sorts
as FCAT is a streamer that's cool I know
I've watched the streams like I can't
picture who's f cat is I have to go back
and see okay Bishop d6 and the Queen's
really misplaced here at some point I
might want to play at five in the
meantime I just want a castle
yeah so I guess if you click the link
that moobot gave it'll take you to like
my HS TV
I'm the sack Oh way to g2s hanging I was
going to sack the c6 whatever I take on
g2 King f1 Bishop h3
let's do it looks fun
there's actually a weird line here after
a king f1 Bishop h3 he can take on c6
twice
and now I play keno fades
and this reminds me of a blockhouse
position like you see this happened so
often in bughouse where like the best
move for white is king g1 and then I
would need like a heavy piece from my
partner
if he plays king g1 here I'd probably
like move the Knights back to f4
okay in this case
I have the most fun 93 check
a 93
[Music]
to
fork I could pre move Bishop g2 unless
he plays kini 1 and I guess I could take
on C 2 oh I could take on C 2 anyway try
name Knight d4 there's too many good
options here
No
indecisive I'm gonna take
see to
there's like a 95% chance he's gonna get
forked in the positions on how and by
fork I mean a king and queen Fork and
we'll play Queen f3 or if he plays Queen
e4 then I played Bishop f5 I mean he's
guaranteed to get for it
I shouldn't give all my secret plans
away because you might be watching
beep silent a little bit's he said hello
say hello back okay he got for it
that feels good yeah I'm I mean I'm
playing this guy cuz I just wanted to
play the lowest rated player who was
seeking a game but starting after this
game I'll play one of these people
some names I recognize Felipe s and gray
Heather
a hatter is back
it's good gray Hatter is watching
okay now I'm up a queen and he resigns
okay so for those of you who are new
usually what I like to do is just have
Siri pick a random number so give me a
random number between 1 and 5 it's fine
it's one it's never one okay so the
first challenger add Miralles slightly
higher rated than my previous opponent
I'm gonna play e4 hello to pH 1256 good
to see you
um if you have a challenge pending be
patient I'll try and get to as many as
possible
this opening replayed this in u.s.
women's championship
I think Jennifer you played this
this is called like the lizard defense
or something I know the best one was to
take and then white should be slightly
better with decent play how long do I
plan the stream for probably like couple
hours but maybe longer maybe shorter
don't really know
yeah Bach is winning the pawn back but
then white eventually gets some kind of
space advantage with the d4 pawn
is my faith
was your faith
five what is this move
I guess a four is kind of a threat I
have to play it for myself
yeah two hours ish is probably a good
number I mean I only started like 15
minutes ago
hello too messy Marvin
for those of you who are just joining if
you want to send me a challenge I
currently have good number of challenges
pending on me chess I don't have my
mouse with me if I had my mouse I would
be more inclined to play bullets maybe I
still will try and play a few bullet
games
it's trying to get back in the rhythm of
things make some orange juice
so I can't complain too much about the
position I mean
I feel like everything's safe
ninety-two pops out as like a nice
candidate move because White has more
space and any trades should favor black
slightly so let's play 92 maybe ideas of
like c4 and d5 maybe even just c3
how often does a 2300 lose for 1900 I'm
sure there's statistics on this pretty
sure you could like download the data
maybe one in 10 one in 8 not sure
after factoring drawers as well
what to do
so now I don't want to play c4 because
he has a night before he's also
preventing d5
just going to play Queen d2
I'm going to try and move quicker to
only when streaming on Twitch
no no that's referring to maybe I'll
play b4 I might take opening
recommendations you guys want so tell me
what opening to play
feel free to
place your recommendations in the chats
there's certain openings I just don't
play like the bond cloud or the the grab
but before is like borderline maybe
playable
I'm gonna play h3 because I don't know
what to do I want to move quickly
I might just like slow play this I might
play king h2 and put books in the center
and just see what black is doing
you
is it a special Mouse comfortable I mean
any Mouse that I've been given I operate
with a thumb it's just a weird habit
ah and that's another reason why I'm
more comfortable using trackpads
h5s are really annoying them because h4
is coming I don't want to play h4 myself
so I'm going to play Queen g5
the threat of night age five
except not really because it's
off-limits what is my threats
there's ideas of my age 5 in the future
might have ideas of like f4 f5
all I know is is g5 is a nice square for
the Queen if he plays a move like Knight
h7 then I have 90 gauge five I think
okay so pH is recommending Kings Indian
attack I always lose in the opening to
one efore that's not good
so if I play you I'll play one efore and
she'll be good for me
Cillian sometimes hate it okay it's okay
to like have a love/hate relationship
with turn openings
hello axe villager good to see you back
thanks for watching everything that I do
ah Queen c7
[Music]
to play f5 or f4 f5
also curious about c4 here because the
knight has to move like night before and
then I can played my f4
looks fun
because when I play night at four I'm a
document bishop
and the pawn in each five
I don't think you can defend everything
you could go for rooked 84
and well for him
so imagine rook takes d4 and I take e6
pawn to e6 I wanted to play Bishop c2
but I can't so rook to d4 maybe I just
take on each five
and we trade
oh and then he ticks with Nathan I have
I don't have Queenie five
am I thinking
you
you
well there is two second increment here
we're time control or +2
debating whether to take on these six
were taking on each five
I'm gonna take 96
it's just more fun to kill his pawn
structure then do this and then target
the pawn I'll probably go for c5 at some
points we'll see what happens
uh yeah a Cobian played an illegal move
and the seif played a move
before making the claim I had to go back
and watch the whole thing it was really
crazy another follow thank you the Gus
to see new followers today
I didn't notice there's a lot of people
on me Ches like there's last time I
looked every like 18,000 people online I
guess it's just because it's a weekend
there's some good numbers I'm gonna
flavor up t3
I just want to play Bishop c2
apply some pressure
you
not 100% sure what's going on here
but all I know is I want to increase the
pressure as much as possible
we'll see what happens maybe he'll flag
seven
kill I've rigged up three on the horizon
and he's about to flag
better
/ tikki 6 it's a nice move as if he
takes back I check name him
and then he just flags that was nice
Thank You jr. Morris one Oh wonderful
that follow I appreciate that I have 14
pending challenges uh real quick what
was blacks mistake in that game
but probably Bach had an okay position
this is a weird moment I just got
another follow but I missed it so
whoever followed feel free to say hi in
the chat
um
actually don't know where black went
wrong the position just got kind of ugly
I was thinking maybe Queen f4 here try
and neutralize things
you lose e6 but then you have king f7
and and then rook t8 and my bishops just
kind of stuck on b3 so anyway good game
let's play another game ah again the
fate will be in the hands of Siri
give me a random number between 1 and
1600 it's going on the edges today Siri
is feeling a bit edgy Freebo lucky you
probably the most recent challenger as
well someone wanted me to play b4 so I'm
playing b4 which is a playable opening I
think play a 3
I play a 3 to avoid this whole line with
like it should be too bit should take
before it should take me 5 and the goal
is just to get some kind of probably
double Fein cattle position efore low
aggressive
let's play c4
this reminds me of like a close Sicilian
except boys just their black is just
completely overextended
Jesse hf2 wants me to play the bots
their BOTS challenging me
RM Naboo thanks for the follow
okay he wants to play d5
play d3
let's play d3 wait a minute
for g3 I'll play d3
if he takes and I would probably play
III because I want my bishop to develop
to d3
if he plays d5 I don't know what to do
III completely unexpected
but that looks like a free pawn
energy for
wait what's going on
okay I don't have much time to think if
I take the pawn IG for
King D to Queen g5 Bishop t4
oh wait he has 9f2 and
that's annoying
beep is 54 immediately
you
okay I'm taking way too much time here
I'm going to take the pawn and play
Bishop c4
I'm expecting night g4s he's gonna play
another unexpected move
yeah Antonio Morales mistake was Bishop
f5
have to go back and see I've already
suppressed the game from my memory
explain the drama with a coab Yoon uh
yeah so there was drama for those of you
who didn't see I was doing commentary
for this event in st. Louis and a Cobian
had this play-off against received our
Bailey so two very strong genes and then
the last rapid game a Cobian made an
illegal move and then instead of
correcting the move the Seif made a move
and then they pause the clock realizing
that the position was just completely
illegal and then there was all this
drama and I was really confusing
um but it was entertaining
[Music]
and now I'm liking my position
as the Queen's attacks
I can just defend the e-pawn very soon
probably like Queens e2
and I'll be up upon good developments
good center just have to focus on time
ask Siri if the circuit if the perk is
sound
and ask that
appear to defense a sound opening
interesting question a great answer
okay h3
next time someone asks me a question I
have no idea to answer to I'm just gonna
say interesting question
ah thank you for the bits gray Hatter I
am aware of my time
I know I have to move quickly
a bit more quickly a Cobian loss
you guys can watch the replay on st.
Louis chess club YouTube channel
but it was fun to like do commentary for
that a weird situation okay I'm gonna
play 94
I have to live up to gray Hatter
and obey his command
else plenty for
a four and all the pawns will be on
light squares
oops except that let's do this move
nice except my rook is gonna hang he's
gonna take on d3 or not
okay now everyone's missing everything
now it's just a matter of moving quickly
with a trackpad
but now I'm up on time
[Music]
but just push center pawns
the video and audio desync it shouldn't
be but maybe it is I don't know okay I
have to push pawns
just going to keep pushing
ah
or not thanks for the follow and thank
you Freebo for the free queen it was
nice of you and it's me next move that
was nice
so it's synced is it decent for the
webcam wait what
it gets better and worse
um
wait a minute is there lag
settings
I could just change it back to my normal
webcam yeah cuz it is like there is lag
even in OBS I'll just switch it back to
my usual
a video it's going to be lower image
quality
but now there should be less lag
um hopefully that's better I don't know
who knows a good game Freebo I was a
weird game probably III was completely
uncalled-for it did kind of confuse me
but Hank bishop d4 I just solved
everything
and then it came down to that time
scramble okay
uh pick a random number between 1 and 15
there's two series going like low and
then high and low
Felipe s human the next victim
okay it's better now that's great why do
you play on me chess as opposed to chess
calm I will answer that
hello Ches pay thanks for watching this
has been kind of late but I should
probably not chess pay just pay is a mod
on every other stream
congratulations recipe I play only chess
because
they've done wonders and like promoting
the stream like if I were to stream on
Ches com
they don't always like promote a stream
on the front page or even feature you on
my chest comm TV and I like the the
tools in the chest a bit better like
just an integration with the analysis
for the fact that you have basically all
tools at your disposal it's easier to
share things Bible play on chess comm
and stream on chess comm for their
events like titled Tuesday and their
arena Kings tournament so I kind of go
back and forth but for my more like
casual streams where I just kind of
don't plan anything I had that usually
pickly chess
um I guess it's just a matter of
preference
no you don't have to mod me haha well
it's too late I guess I could on my
chest pay but then I would feel weird
about it
um I mean the more mods the merrier
right Queen d2
some kind of perk opening
I'm really surprised I've never played
Felipe s before I know he's challenging
me many times before Thank You Cheerios
6 2 3 for the follow
do you appreciate that usually I'm odd
people who like I've like seen around
and I know who are like decent human
beings thanks for the other follow me
open upstream labs
followers are coming to quickly ID seven
let's find out of three preventing e5
a joke 1724 thank you for that follow
except both casual and rated I don't
really have a preference Syria is just
choosing my my by challenges so
that's how it's working for now
Chesire Cat thanks for the follow
see five is probably a good move here
I could play d5 and go into some benoni
[Music]
or I could just take
or I could play Bishop h6
I'm gonna play Bishop h6
like a decent move I can take
some dragon position I gave lactic sunji
for its some dragon where I think the
structure is slightly more favorable for
whites
because night bd7 is kind of weird
like do this
f3g 4-h 4-h 5
we'll see what happens
goodnight axe villager thanks for
watching
villager it's already late for him
in Europe somewhere
Rick thanks for the follow
so I'm calculating like a 5d tegi 5 and
9.5 the problem is Bishop take f5 as
Queen gets defended so I'm gonna start
with just f3
and then I mean hopefully just a simple
attack honey I'm in Western Europe okay
time difference
you can give me anytime control
I'm not
what's the right word I'm not
stereotyping against certain time
controls because of the people I'm
accepting are completely random
I think a lot of people are challenging
me templates I mean if you want to you
could challenge me just a slower game
maybe five
you
why has options here and could play e6
like Queen g5
play f4
go for a six
move
45 45 I would be very I'm like if Siri
like picked a 45 45 game for me I would
probably have to veto it
but who knows
that would keep me here for a long time
and I take e six doesn't make sense to
pre move because he clearly wasn't going
to take only six
guess I can reinforce the pond
is 180 plus 180 really a time control
feel like that's just abuse
to most people challenging me to
reasonable reasonable things
I should watch out for my time
reminding me not to flag oh that's a
nice move I have five
is crumbling
you
okay the other three think there's only
been three games so far um sad finished
first Felipe s not sure what happened
there
the tactus
kind of slow usually as back you want to
you want to be a lot more ambitious
maybe start with Knight c5 go for Queen
a5 Bishop e6 and he sacked the D pawn at
some point
okay I'm gonna accept another challenge
17 pending challenges give me a random
number between 1 and 17 I did not want
that
give me a random number between 1 and 17
serious like flawed today challenge
number one cube stack good luck
let's wait for
neither five was not a cheapo
also it's called knife f5 according to
Ben Feingold let's fire Mora Mora is
always fun
suck one black plays Knight f6 please
don't play 906 yes
wait what he's still talking
what's my aura okay yeah usually when I
play little more I play it differently
than other people I play it like a Grand
Prix
I just want to develop like this
what do you think is the best way to
play in Seoul London actually gave some
video lectures how to play against the
London
um you can find one on st. Louis chess
club it's called black wins against e4
and in that lecture I showed to Young's
or actually very good recommendations
against London
I could use random.org but Siri is more
more fun to talk to
and also more efficient what do I think
about combatting b3 or b4 with a reverse
London it's possible
um but against b3 or before I like to
play e5 just because
it applies a lot more pressure to black
earlier and those openings I think it's
it's better if you can try and punish
your opponent for playing suspiciously
early on
thank you for the random.org link I'm
probably not gonna use it though I'm
just comfortable with Siri even though
it's being weird today
there's some ideas of like e5 and 94 now
especially five
D 6 is going to be week
you
Scot a challenge for an unlimited
correspondence game I probably can't
accept
because that could take forever
you
okay this is about to be very fun let's
start with 96
you
the question is how to continue I
none of Tuzla threats
while I was going to just be trapping
the Knights on g4
okay I'll play Queen you too
preventing 9f2 probably for broking
bishop take c1
not after rook take c1 it's just a great
position for lights
145
so confused
Oh d4 d5 he means what do I do against
early 94
how early 94 the if it's too early you
can usually like play f3
I'm gonna play this move
and think blights winning something here
it helps if you give me a line so like
d4 d5 I assume Bishop f4 Knight f6 III
then I mean 94 right away it usually
doesn't make sense
either because of f3 or just night 92
allas allas l13 first time watching Wow
if anyone's a first-time watcher make
yourself known in the chat not too many
of those people these days but it's good
to see
what's the troll gambit is that a real
thing or is that just made up
but yeah this is completely winning for
whites methyl Eagle okay I looked into
105 as b3 before
okay yeah if you want to be comfortable
as back then
[Music]
usually what you can do is just pick one
set up and then stick with it
King wiki with the emotes
that
okay I can take this I think
and then blackheads like all these
pieces hanging this is hanging this is
hanging this is hanging
we can take the night's and now this is
hanging and this is still hanging
radical freedom thanks for the follow
hmm
yeah I am curious like how many people
watch the YouTube videos but like you
haven't caught a livestream
because I do post most of the streams on
YouTube
but it's um I don't put much effort into
promoting like YouTube content it's just
another a matter of archiving things
I'll probably put more effort into
YouTube at some point
Treiber account is growing let's play 96
I also wanted to ask people like what
type of streams you want to see if these
viewer challenge streams are something
you enjoy or if people want to see like
more Q&A streams or more streams like
involving opening analysis or bullet or
whatever so feel free to give me
feedback
but for now I usually just do what I
feel like or what I feel like people
would enjoy
speaking of enjoyment physicians really
enjoyable
I want to play tonight I got seven kings
and Queen Tiki six
with force mates could probably pre move
Queen to g6
take that risk maybe I should
bad could it be
okay maybe I want to play like queen g6
but even if he plays like King f8 I play
Queen diggy six
ninety-eight
that would be nice so Lucas wants having
a little bit of everything your
challenges
which is sad you do a weird opening
streams
that would be interesting
studies game studies could be cool
I'm not meeting this guy yet
I guess I have to trade Queens to
do this
for complete domination
not sure what the thread is maybe just a
six
Black is just paralyzed
about to flag
let's play e6
too much fun
way too much fun please play King g7
don't flag
oh he flagged
just wanted to like just promotes
what is the fanciest mate I kind of
wanted to throw it to a knight promoting
to Queen is also kind of elegance
promoting to rook is the most elegant if
I promote to rook and then he does this
and then i checkmate him like that three
rooks so beautiful
I miss me after rook f8
is this pleading to me
not sure
I don't see maid in that line
um okay that was a interesting game I
really wish this mate happened that
would have been tweet-worthy uh oh thank
you for the new subscriber Lucas
appreciate that
okay let's move on 22 pending challenges
okay I'm gonna play someone give me a
random number between one and 22
okay it's either high or low
so 20 so this is 20 to 21 as Ana Donald
Duck
good luck
what opening em I'm gonna play play a
London some discussion of the London and
the chat except here I can't play a
London
like neither three or Bishop f4 are just
bad news so I'll take my pet line
um there's a bot challenging me because
I don't know that wants to play me
I think BOTS have some magnetic
attraction to me or something I don't
know
Scott chess thanks for the follow yeah
this is actually a pretty interesting
line which a lot of players just don't
know what to do against the night
invades g6 and then whites pretty happy
here
oh the young kid streamers probably
pesca
I could play I could play blindfolded
maybe I'll play a few games blindfolded
spice it up perhaps the next game I was
doing that my previous stream
and it was uh I actually don't mind
blindfold chess it's good training
although the ancient gamer thanks for
watching
the problem with fine folders when you
get low in time it just becomes a
complete mess
I'm happy with this opening though
Bishop 96 by having two bishops
ready to Castle queenside
our life is pretty good
who do I consider the top young chess
talents today um it's a good question
but I'm growing so old that it's hard to
keep track of like the young talents but
I mean I wonder leaning in solemn at US
Championships the
I mean he's playing very well amazing
performance from protest League
and other than that I mean okay there's
so many young players these days or just
solely the chess
this uh this kid streamer on me chess
Pesce beat me the other day was a few
weeks ago and he uh he's only like eight
years old or something or nine years old
pretty crazy
so this is more of a positional game
those lights are kind of tied down
like to play c4
but also just develop
okay I'm going to develop
so he sent me a challenge so I have 20
pending challenges
anyone just joining um I can't accept
all the challenges at once
so every time a game finishes I just
accept a random challenge Siri gives me
a random number and I go off that so
everyone gets a fair chance
eighty-four
and
Eliza's nights mission accomplished is
now I'm at least winning an exchange
you probably had to take on d4 or play
rook e8
could give a similar problem with
Simon's is they take forever and they
take so much energy I'm much happier
just playing one game at a time
but I'm not against doing a sign was
just not today
okay rook 287
is asking if you can suggest I could
make a tournament to
I am planning to do more streams in the
coming weeks I'll be home for three
weeks before I leave for Europe ooh
president Donald Duck resigned real
quick opening lesson this is a fun
opening for whites Scott announced his
board a lot of people who play c5 is
black they'll just kind of stumble into
this line then they'll run into 94 and
they don't know what to do and they
eventually walk into d6 I walk into 96
uh Thank You Lucas for 101 bits yeah I
there will be more streams
um sorry I've got a text message because
I'm popular uh nope
400 bits
I think he's saying nope to the
tournament
but I don't know I'm gonna do a
tournament in the future but let me give
some opening lesson here the best move
for black in this position is Knight f6
with the idea that after Knight takes e5
Queen a5 check and this is actually very
reasonable for black in d5 coming it's
also reasonable for whites
I mean Bishop error pretty
straightforward development for whites
so so this is basically the best line
for both sides after g6 e5 Thank You
Sammy for the follow
someone asking about Queen b6 problem
with Queen b6 is that after take take
uh it's just a worst version of this
Knight f6 line because white has the
move here probably something like but
not e4 because Queen B for a check
maybe something like c3 ideas between d4
one more line I would like to show
because some people as black played d5
which is actually not a great move
because after Knight takes e5 Queen 85
check it looks very similar but White
has a great move here
Pawnee for
hey Hatter it says great Hatter is
number one
not sure
which is being weird
anyway e4 is a great move because after
a pawn to e4 Queen g4 and then the
position opens up Whiteland wins back
upon there's a bishop pair so that's my
secret opening preparation that's really
all I know in this line objectively the
best move for why this d5 but usually it
might go along with blacks comfort zone
so that's why I like to take on c5
anyway let's pick another another random
player give me a random Reyes give me a
random number between 1 and 21 Siri is
very flawed today hey I'm playing Apollo
bot I've never played Apollo bot before
I have no idea what to expect
ah but it's not that high rated it is
casual
let's play a London
also confidence
it's playing automatic moves he's my
secret prep c5 the move the easy he's
probably going to play b5
at b5 now if I'm not mistaken the main
line is eat live but this is not aligned
to go into against a computer
assistant would provide by random
numbers there's such thing as better and
on numbers I'm pretty sure a 5s a move
I've only looked up this line like once
someone played this against me in like a
blitz tournament I had no idea what to
do and now I'm out of book
complain I take b5 take b5
taken d6
I mean neither three looks simple enough
to develop
idea if before then I have 94
if he takes one of you five see five
should be hanging and any lines so I
like my center control it's just a
question can I maintain the center of
control
because I might be sacking upon
o'clock might get away with taking only
five
I had no idea what's going on
I can take on that five
and maybe like 9h for
maybe 96 is coming
you
okay maybe not the best position
and I h4
d6 Queen to d3 in Queen d7
[Music]
could go for some g4 idea - okay it's
the only thing I see
so he starts with Queen d7
each six Bishop f6
you
I hate playing BOTS cuz they're so like
non-emotional
even more anonymous
me
okay I'm gonna play AG for
I'm just going all out I have no idea
how this pot operates so I don't know
like what sort of weaknesses to targets
but hopefully I can't like see the depth
of my attack
like sometimes that's how you'd be pots
you just like continually increase
pressure until they collapse a queen g7
probably not a great move they're
expecting a five or something I have to
move quickly
h6 ORAC g1 start with rock g1
you
okay attacking the Knights
annoying
pleasant
by age 6 this was actually getting very
complex just kind of the worst fear when
you're playing a bot
there's no time to calculate
and I would assume the bottle has a
capacity so I calculate pretty deeply
take care
Aref to is going to be attacked
wait I've take you six bishop tg6 King
h8 okay well that's not happening
let's just develop and defend
probably a decent move
you
I have to take
wait do I can I take on at 7:00
Bishop e6
like rook take f7 Bishop e6
take back
you
I'm so scared he's gonna flag me
good Queens
but now I'm just going into an end game
like just down a pond or he's just gonna
make me
can't stick there
please plunder
Thunder okay
sorry but I'm not reading the chat
because I'm kind of preoccupied
trying to hold on for dear life
Knight f4 is coming
this is so unpleasant at least my bishop
is decent
do that move almost flags there
you
you
three seconds left
for a draw
true though
you
and I can get the King to e4
targets and weaknesses
you
feel like I shouldn't be surviving the
song but somehow kind of still alive
bring the rook around
Thank You McGurk 52 for the follow
and go after the a pond
don't know why he gave me a pawn like
that
Oh
maybe that's why
you
okay we trade
put the rook back here
you
who is white drying this
sure
you
might be drawing this
you
pretty sure I'm drawing this now
please don't play king and rook versus
king and rook these don'ts
oh he's playing King Brooke
oh it's so annoying
these
yes okay
I drew I don't know that's my bush man I
really liked is just an epic failure but
that was interesting I took a lot of
like focus been playing the human
especially with a knight there are so
many fork possibilities there's one
moment there
so easy to walk into a fork
again where it was
I don't know interesting game I might
have to go over that game later and like
see how strong the spot actually is and
like do some research but anyway uh
let's play another game with 24 pending
challenges so many people want to play
I saw Nakamura somewhere that was a
hallucination or maybe it was no mala
okay uh let's pick a number
give me a number between 1 and 25
these numbers are so easy today three
workplane love cash
good luck love cash
what do I do by London again why not
the bread-and-butter opening
you
wait what number was great Hatter is
great hunter one gray header is one
yeah so we have the one of the most like
trendy London lines ever
the sky actually kind of knows what he's
doing
maybe
maybe not another text message
National Italian beef day no idea
I might have to end the stream early
just for that
you
okay Queenie - I'm usually happy with
these positions we're like black trades
early on g3 thank you moles finish for
the follow because now White House open
each file 95 looks strong
ideas of d4 g5 coming
my knots before
g5 coming soon
Black's kind of stuck too
as if he castles he loses f7 he can't
take on D Phi on e5 o King e7 such a sad
move
played bishop g6 by don't think that's a
great move
you
it's going to Castle queenside
King play King B 1 and B okay
he wants to play b4
I want to get the night to f5
but that might be difficult but maybe
not maybe Knight f3 knight for and then
Mike dream will come true
thank you avenge re for the follow Kiki
seven like Karpov I wonder how many
people got that reference
if I remember I'll go and find that King
g7 Karpov game kappa play c4
that was if I remember crack that I was
like a really nice game kingi seven out
of nowhere
so the plan is to wait till I want to
expand as I can
yeah the plans to keep the files closed
and build up pressure in the center
you
look
I might be ending this somewhat early
you got Italian beef
maybe not I don't know plans are being
made
okay so blacks not threatening anything
so I'm just gonna play some a slow
improving moves I'm gonna try and play
quickly too so I only have 45 seconds
so popular
you
okay a3 okay time not to text or look at
the chat after you the focus
I'll triple up on the the e-file
Oh geforce hanging
anymore
someday I want to like take on f7
might be difficult though
a tactical wizard five you can challenge
me to anything you want because I'm
accepting random challenges also it's
good to see you back tactical wizard you
were one of the first people ever to
watch my stream
six here
you
f-five always on pissant
someway Brooker seven coming could have
played rook F seven last move but
even better now because I can take with
pawn
whereas my mate
we just simple
unis
we go oh that's not meat okay
that's why there's free moving
I'm a king of slippery
King is very slippery
okay I flatten those difficult you don't
know why you have a five on your name
maybe the first four tackle Wizards were
taken
so I still have 25 pending challenges
any takeaways from that game
I think it was just a pleasant position
for whites but usually is black if you
recommend one line actually thank you
Western meadow meadow for the follow
the line I recommend is to play Knight
h5 here you have to play in this exact
position and there's a good game a few
good games the first game was onigiri
against resi so and mazi played this
line got a very nice position is black
um and for those of you who don't know
the kini 7 Karpov game let's go to
Google in East 7 Karpov
as a plaque
there we go
should be the game pretty sure it was
calm ski
we'll go to some study
I think the computer is just really slow
today I'm not sure why though
I still use
by sex
here we go
it's a classic game
clonise I think this might be shared
with someone
I'll make this public to is just a bunch
of good games to to know
public
so if anyone wants like a collection I
think I only have like five games and to
study but if anyone wants to like view
it or look at these on your own time you
can click the link in the chat but let's
add this to copy the URL again paste
so I think this is one of karpas most
famous games
it was just like out of nowhere it is
like Keeney seven but it's such a strong
move
idea being that Queen protects her rook
and if I'm not mistaken there's threats
of like g5 also like why can't play
Bishop g5 anymore
so yeah Alice Lee chess has many studies
and it's great for like it's a great
educational resource if you're looking
for tactics or like opening analysis you
can usually search for what you're
looking for
probably do more with like organizing my
own studies but it's still a future
which has a ton of potential so
- Karpov -
Karpov just won upon
and then he just like went on to win the
game
the panel six
I'm just zooming through I just want to
get a sense of what happened but yeah
Karpov is really good at chess
so anyway that's a good one to save just
for a future knowledge also to show
students I just have them think in this
position black to move play the the best
move give them like five or ten tries
they still won't find kini seven
um yeah one tip if you're really like
disorganized with studies because you
have a lot of them and you want to
organize them what I do is organize
everything in bookmarks I'm not sure if
people can see this
and in my bookmark are
and I actually don't want to like share
all my bookmarks well like if you're
using Google Chrome I guess I can share
this no I don't want to share that
either
what do i sir
Secretariat like this like you can
basically organize your your bookmarks
if you have like a bunch of studies like
have one folder for openings or one
folder for like students or whatever or
like tactics and then it just makes it
easier to it to access so those that
these are my twitch bookmarks but anyway
let's play another game
give me a random number between 1 and 26
it's 2222 okay so 26 25 24 23 22 Joshi
washi rated almost 1,300
good luck
going for efore
that's my test Vikings gambits haven't
played this in a while
yeah I would think I would hope most
people know what bookmarks are but I
feel like not everyone uses and uses
bookmarks to write their their full
potential
a five strange move
I can take
very Heather thanks for the hundred bits
by thanks for watching
that's a see you go
five is white snout in Queen age five
check
it's a hard threat sistah is Knight f6
runs into ft e5
what does back to here
you
you should not always copy your
opponents
you
of course there's this line if he plays
that s6 here I can play g7 and promotes
ship g7 is probably the best move
but then I can just take
nevermind I'm just winning material
is this an opening this is eight and
opening but it's not a great opening for
black and black is just losing material
but maybe it's a peace sacrifice not
entirely sure
could be a peace sacrifice
seems like things
any bit of compensation here but I don't
think there's that much
yes you don't know what bookmarks are
then just type into YouTube like
managing bookmarks and it's just a good
productivity tip
okay so I slip a piece
but I have no developments
negative
start with Bishop b5
the logic that is I just want to trade
so if he plays like 94 I can play Bishop
a4 I'll hit him a c3
if you played my b4 I'd probably do the
same thing
be boolean 24 good to see you
I can do this move
d3 was another possibility
you
maybe I should have played d3 now d3 is
incredibly weak
thanks for the one bits
so I have to play kini too
we move
I don't know why I'm putting so much
stress and afraid into the scheme and
other piece just gonna play 92 develop
well your name is Vishal okay
I'll try and remember that pretty bad
with names but
I'll try my best
I don't know what the plan here is for
lights
like b3 Bishop b2 91
because I don't know what blacks plan is
either d4 is a bit strange
now I have a clear plan
should open
is threatening rookie for plain ig3
you
I've never had this many pending
challenges of 27 pending challenges the
ridiculous amounts I and I think it's
slowing down my computer to like it
feels so laggy like there's a delay when
I click
it's pretty significant delay and then
when I scroll
and
okay
I'm pretty happy here now as I can
queenside castle and just completely
play around the bishop on d3
I can take care in the night age five
nine age five is a bad move to pre move
because if you were to play rook f8 he
would make me on f1
okay now it's it's winning
or in Atlanta Georgia that's where a
been flying all this I'm not mistaken
good game
how can I castle I would castle like
this
but I can't Castle kingside
I guess this is a nice position to
demonstrate castling rules as you can't
castle through check your King can't
move through a square which is attacked
but your rook can go castling queenside
would be legal assam kingside illegal
hope that makes sense
uh I am American I was born in America
serve myself American
um that then Feingold is a good friend
of mine too
um this chess Center is only one mile
from your house that's cool I want to go
to the chess Center at some point
because I built their whole websites I I
did their logo I did their like online
branding so I should visit one of these
days okay give me a random number
between 129 the answer is 13 hey finally
like a normal number uh this is gonna be
annoying to count one two I'm just gonna
count with my finger three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen is schwarz something
Schwarz Cora maybe this is a guy who I
thought was Nakamura the ends with Aurra
okay good luck
what I want to play
play for again be as aggressive as
possible
um Sphinx oo is asking if there's any
chance we could play
um yeah there's a chance we can play if
Siri gives me the number that
corresponds with your your challenge
then we can definitely play but it's
completely random today I'm sorry for
those who really want a game but I mean
serious determining the fate of the
universe
looks like this guy might be playing a
hippo
I very much sense a hippo happening
which means have to be even more
aggressive
play bishop here
I'm expecting a six
then I'm debating if f5 makes any sense
just to try and disturb his his hippo
let's play on five
vishal thanks for following i remembered
your name to answer the m49
followed by many other numbers a hippo
is when black does this sort of setup
usually usually if it's unchallenged
it's it's not that bad so like double
feigning hello and then II 66 but
usually if you realize your opponent's
playing the hippo and you can disturb
their setup then good things should
happen
you
thought I'm winning material but maybe
not wanted to lie play something like
before then he can take on e4
we'll just play d3
the whole idea is this night is tied
down to defending a 6 so the threat is
to play before his knight would move and
then I win a six pot
takes on a five might have a very strong
move like Knight g5 or something
um
Shaul asking which state I live in I'm
currently in Illinois but I travel so
much that I don't really have a like a
set place that I live for the time being
like the lasts
last two months I've I've stayed like
maybe 10 to 15 different places
I think I can take care
yeah I'm been living the nomad life
you
you
actually trying to calculate this
because he takes on d5
take on e6 she has to take back with
pawn
otherwise very bad things happen to him
if he doesn't take with pawn as he could
take with Knight Navy
hmm
okay Knight g5
and like I treat low rated player with
respect I try and treat everyone with
respect even if they don't respect me
back but
I don't know usually it's a good habit
if you just always strive to play the
best moves
no matter the rating of your opponents
there is a time where like I didn't
respect low rated opponents and then I
lost I had I got upset a lot just
because I was being a lot more careless
and still will occasionally happen
this position but how do I win
to win I can take on a seven maybe
in physics with Queen and Wendy five
fix with King
I can castle
I mean night take f7 is a type of move
which probably shows no respect
given that I'm essentially hoping this
will work out I haven't fully calculated
move
I might actually get into trouble here
well we'll see
the shawl thanks for watching I will see
you in the future
but at least he's thinking
it's a good sign oh and now I'm
realizing I have very simple move if
King to got7 I can just play Queen f3
and win back material and everything's
good
it was originally a hope chespin because
now it's just good chess I take off
seven was
probably a sign move
I could have castled to
okay blacks under pressure
about Queen f3
rook
you
who's going to Castle queenside
you
considering playing Knight e5
so I feel like my night is more valuable
than his rook
I didn't want to allow him to Castle
queenside online
and now that f7 is no longer here the 96
is just are less defended
and there might also be like tricks with
queen h5
at some points
even like queen g6 queen h5 could be
pretty strong
you
okay this might be my last game
-
show
or like create disappointments
wait a minute okay let's just take the
night um I don't want it to be my last
game but what's my uptime
ah move arts
wait there's so many questions here I
respect eating the rook maybe too slow
and greedy
um Wow so much respect from
the John G
[Music]
but don't respect everything I do okay
I'm gonna play Queen h5o it's time to
kill well I've only been streaming for
90 minutes that's kind of a long time a
great two is asking how much of your
thinking process is intuition
a lot of it is intuition
especially these like quicker games but
during a tournament game I will rely a
lot more on like concrete calculation
I like to like be sure of things
like here okay I kind of have to
calculate soukous
of options
like mega sevens a move
might just refine the tuition here d4
Bishop d6
you
I'm just going to play d4 and castle
Bishop a6 I didn't even consider it's a
funny move
the problem with Bishop Asics he doesn't
have to take it he could like take on g2
or something
your cafe interesting move
I think now it's time to take
my king is actually pretty safe funny
one
if he takes with nights I have Bishop g5
Dick's with Queen I still have Bishop g5
and in the sign I'm and then be castling
queenside with a mating attack
you
it's looking nice
you
where is it mates
when h3 I guess
this'll be good enough I'll have some
windmill their king bee 897 or hell flag
funk 18
okay
know why but my computer is just a
really slow game
26 challenges
I feel bad many people want to play
I'm so little time
um
[Music]
energy and like I'm texting all these
people
we're gonna get Italian beef
so here's a plan
back to Regis
open
great ooh uh i do i do streams i'm gonna
try and do a lot more streams to clean
weeks but I'll do streams where I do
like Q&A where it's just completely
dedicated to answering like viewer
questions but I can answer your question
uh between between studying and playing
I think it's important to have a balance
I usually recommend like two what you're
more passionate about like if you're
more passionate about playing than play
if you're more passionate about studying
then study but you should try and make
an effort to do both like if you play a
lot of games make an effort to go go
over every single game you play even if
it's just like checking opening theory
or running it through with engine if you
study a lot try and like apply what you
study in your actual games if you're
studying openings or if you're studying
like attacking chess or whatever
oh yeah maybe not it's not the most
detailed answer but hopefully that gives
you some more inspiration
and then fowl glorious is asking when I
calculate do I see a mental board yeah
like
I could close my eyes and essentially
like know where all the pieces are in
this position or any position that I put
enough focus on and usually it's a
matter of chunking which is kind of like
a memory technique where basically there
you see like patterns like this this
sort of structure is so common in chess
I don't have to like look at every
single individual piece I just like
remember that chunk and it it's just
kind of second nature so a lot of
positions that you like kind of conjunct
different areas of the board and then
the more chess you play them the easier
it is just to kind of recognize
different patterns so um I don't mind
the questions I love answering questions
it's just I'm tired I'm hungry so before
I go I kind of want to accept it in one
more channel I wanted to accept one more
challenge not too many people are
streaming Oh cuz everyone's playing
Chicago open that's probably why there
is no simple way to force your opponents
into a tactical line but I will say that
if your pieces are on good squares and
your pieces are coordinated and you have
a harmonious setup and tactics are bound
to happen so sometimes you have to learn
positional chess to achieve certain
tactical positions
um I wanted to read someone
let's go to twitch and see who else is
dreaming
typing chess
are the chest brows really streaming
my gosh my computer's
so so slow
this is just so laggy I don't know if
I'm going to be able to read someone
bear with me
you
I'll have to fix whatever is going on
here I might just have to restart my
computer reload everything okay who is
streaming
[Music]
komm streamers
Oh
I honestly don't recognize
people so I'm gonna end it here thanks
everyone for watching
I'll be back at some points
in the meantime
um I want to say anything no I just
wanted to wish everyone a Happy National
Italian beef day and enjoy enjoy your
Saturday nights goodbye